okay so the book of bubba fed episode 5
brings the mandalorian back to our
screens as we see what's happened to the
character after he said goodbye to grogu
in it he ends up reuniting with the
mandalorians that we last saw on navarro
and it's through the armor that we have
more and more of the backstory of
mandalore filled in throughout this
video we're gonna be breaking down
everything we know about the night of a
thousand tears whilst also discussing
what we think could be happening in the
future of the saga if you enjoyed the
video then please hit the thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe as it takes to
commando without the way thank you for
clicking this here thank you now let's
get into our breakdown of the night of a
thousand tears
okay so this fateful event has been
mentioned throughout several star wars
shows and films there's also an event
known as the grey purge that we will be
touching upon but on the whole these two
separate things often get confused with
one another to boil it down to its
simplest terms the night of a thousand
tears occurred when the empire is
sending countless tie bombers that
completely ransacked the planet
mandalore we see flashes of this playing
out in episode 5 and the event somewhat
parallels the real-life crystal knack or
knight of broken glass which was carried
out by the nazis in 1938 this involves
several of hitler's forces destroying
jewish-owned properties such as stores
synagogues and their homes the night
actually got its name due to all the
glass that was destroyed during the
event and it's one of the darkest
moments in the last hundred years now
the way that we see the event playing
out in the show also somewhat parallels
the opening of terminator 2 and after
the initial bombing droids were sent in
to kill the survivors these included
probe droids that lit up the wreckage
whilst the kx security ones killed
anyone left alive now beyond this we
know from the expanded law that gunships
also patrolled the areas and picked off
anyone who managed to survive the
initial onslaught watching it play out
as harrowing and the knight is
remembered as one of the lowest points
in mandalorian history it's been
immortalized in songs and from what
we've seen of the star wars canon thus
far the mandalorians never really
recovered from it in the brief glimpses
that we get in the episode we also see
the sundari being destroyed which is the
giant dome-like structure that is
actually the capital of mandalore now
the empire carried this out to not only
destroy most of the population but they
also wish to severely deplete the
mandalorian forces in the latest episode
of the mandal sorry the book of boba
fett the armor talks about how concordia
was also a part of this and both the
moon and mandalore are the only places
in the galaxy where bescor can be farmed
from we learned from the armor that had
she not been on the moon of concordia
with the rest of her sect that they
wouldn't have survived albescar is one
of the strongest medals in the entire
galaxy and those seeking after it have
shed blood over the millennia in order
to get their hands on it this is very
much mirrored in the darksaber the
ceremonial blade that was created by tor
vizsler bisla was the first ever
mandalorian jedi and over the millennia
the blade has been passed down through
combat to decide who the leader of
mandalore should be now during the clone
wars a different way of thinking rose up
in mandalore which was spearheaded by
duchess satine this took a more pacifist
stance than what had come before and
though it was accepted by the majority
there were some that broke away from
this most notably this was a group known
as the death watch who wanted to return
to their more warrior roots amongst
their ranks was bokeh tan and the
splinter cell was led by a man named
prie vizsler he was defeated in combat
by darth maul and slowly he set out to
take over the planet which is when the
jedi intervened bo had broken away from
this and along with ahsoka she managed
to capture more however this happened
during order 66 which led to the great
purge on the jedi during this time the
empire took over control of mandalore
and it's been sought after ever since
some time later beau was gifted the
darksaber by sabine wren and she managed
to rally together the mandalorians to
fight the empire as we know this failed
and she's somewhat regarded as a
cautionary tale because it's in this
attack that the imperials ransacked
mandalore and she lost the darksaber
gideon referred to the dead creating
fields of bodies and since then the
mandalorians have hidden out wherever
they could however with the fall of the
empire they have a chance to take the
planet back once more i think that going
forward the mandalorian season three
will probably focus on this now belle
badly wants to wield the darksaber so
that she can lead her people once more
but right now mando is currently in
possession of it i actually think that
going forward amanda will end up being
the leader of the planet and then things
like the show title his name and so on
will make way more sense i don't know if
it'll be contested by beau but just the
way things are going they seem to be
setting up mando as the rightful ruler
the mandalorian people are actually made
up of several different species and
therefore a foundling taking charge
would be possible hell you could even
have grogu hell you could even have
watto but i really don't think that it's
gonna be bo because of how she's looked
down upon she removes her helmet all the
time and the armor even says that you
can't do this and be a real mandalorian
you've got to cleanse yourself in the
living waters just for showing your face
which makes me wonder who mando is even
growing that mustache for anyway let me
know below what you think is gonna
happen and i hope you enjoyed the video
we are in competition right now giving
away three copies of an mc box out of
your choice on the 30th of january and
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is to like the video make
sure you subscribe with notifications on
and drop a comment below with your
thoughts on the show you pick the
comments at random at the end of the
month and the winners are the last one
on screen right now so that's you then
message me on twitter at heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
episode 5 which will be linked on screen
right now we went over all the easter
eggs we could find talked a bit more in
depth about everything and yeah just had
a really good time because it's a really
good episode if not then thanks for
sitting through the video i've been paul
you've been the best and i hope to see
you in the next one enjoy the rest of
your week i'm out peace
[Music]
you